plusieurs heures avant les mesures de
confinement annoncé par le président de
la république le bourg de sa puce semble
déjà paralysé ici tout le monde
connaissait la femme de 86 ans décédée
hier du coroner
oui c'était c'était une dame qu'on
voyait régulièrement par sa fenêtre
qu'on salue est bien entendu
là ça reste situation très difficile
très grave pour nous c'est grave mais
c'est triste pour nos pensées avoir été
exposé en contact avec la guitare et ça
détourne pas du tout non non pas du tout
c'est pas qu'à toi
tu sortais beaucoup donc n'a pas eu de
contact à 13h tous les restaurants de la
ville sont invités à baisser leurs
rideaux
y compris les établissements
touristiques du bord de mer on pensait
aussi que le plat à emporter on aurait
pu faire comme en france les plats à
emporter et ont été autorisés et ils
sont passés nous dire que même les plats
à emporter ne sont pas autorisés ça
représente j'imagine ces mesures un
sérieux manque à gagner pour un
établissement comme le vôtre oui c'est
comme un trafic jamais une crise
économique la deûle annonce de ce
premier décès dans la commune la ville a
pris des mesures pour protéger sa
population
l'interdiction de tout rassemblement
dans les lieux et espaces publics la fin
des commerces ambulants de la
restauration la fermeture de tous les
services de la ville à l'exception de
l'état civil en service minimum et cela
sans information particulière des
autorités sanitaires
nous sommes isolés face à une situation
qui dépasse tout le monde on en convient
maintenant l'appui des services de
l'état pour justement organisé la
communication organiser la prévention
sur le territoire de la commune seraient
bienvenus seuls les commerces vitaux
reste ouvert et là aussi certains n'ont
pas attendu les dernières consignes
présidentielles pour prendre des mesures
de protection comme on est amené à
sierre ya des gens qui pètent être sont
porteurs du virus
et pour éviter de contaminer le
personnel qui après par la suite
éventuellement servir des personnes
saines et qui ne sont pas forcément à
tête
donc du coup on préfère limiter la
propagation ainsi quoi autant de mesures
comprises et acceptées par les ducéens
et même par les plus jeunes
franchement c'est super et spéciale moi
même je suis choqué je ne reconnaît même
pas ma commune en jouer c'est un truc de
ouf comme le temps s'est arrêté à
sainte-luce après ce premier décès qui
semble avoir fait prendre conscience aux
habitants de la gravité de la situation